let the function f be defined by f of X
is equal to ax to the third plus B where
a and B are constants if f of 0 is equal
to 2 and f of 2 is equal to 3 which of
the following must be true when they say
is greater than 0 b is greater than 0 a
is less than P so let's look at each of
these constraints right over here so we
have f of X is equal to a X to the third
plus B and they say f of 0 so what is f
of 0 going to be f of 0 well this whole
term is going to be a x 0 to the third
so that's just going to be 0 so f of 0
is going to be equal to B which they
tell us is equal to 2 so we know that B
is equal to 2 so now we know that f of X
is equal to ax to the third plus 2 then
they tell us f of 2 is 3 well what is f
of 2 and I'll just switch colors
somewhat arbitrarily f of 2 now is going
to be a times 2 to the third power plus
2 well this is going to be equal to 8 a
plus 2 and they tell us they tell us
that that is equal to 3 that is equal to
3 so we have eight a plus 2 is equal to
3 now we can solve for a actually so
let's subtract two from both sides and
we get 8 a is equal to 8 is equal to 1
divide both sides by 8 a is equal to 18
so which of these are true a is greater
than 0 that's true B is a greater than 0
that's true a is less than B 1 8th is
less than 2 that's true as well so all
three are true